oh ce sont des entreprises qui sont je
dirais en fête permanente
on va pas obliger les autres toujours
pro texte actuel à garder leurs salariés
ça n'a pas de sens ça fait longtemps que
je soutiens l'idée d' emploi garanti
c'est à dire on propose un emploi toutes
ces personnes ont maintenant qu'elle
retrouve un autre jeune dont on n'a
aucune vision aucune
et ça c'est malheureusement dans tous
les domaines au lieu de dépenser des
milliards comme ça pour rien il faudrait
mieux les dépensés pour former les gens
et les replacer ailleurs
[Musique]
après une journée d'attenté la
composition du nouveau gouvernement
dévoilé dans quelques minutes
mais jean castex a passé le week end et
une partie de la journée avec le chef de
l'état pour élaborer sa nouvelle équipe
et un cap déjà affichée par le président
de la république quand le gouvernement
devra oeuvrer à la reconstruction
économique social environnemental et
culturel du pays
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez en direct sur rt france pour
cette édition spéciale la présentation
du troisième gouvernement du mandat des
manuels macron est imminente
tout est prêt dans la cour de l'elysée
vous le voyez sur ces images
et comme le veut la tradition c'est
alexis colère le secrétaire général de
l'elysée avec qui va annoncer les noms
des nouveaux ministres sur le perron du
palais présidentiel une étape clé pour
le chef de l'état il espère en effet
relancer son quinquennat a marqué
notamment par la pandémie dont on
connaît les conséquences désastreuses
alors l'exécutif a tenu à annoncer le
nouveau gouvernement dès lundi pour
illustrer sa volonté mise en oeuvre
rapide du nouveau cap présidentielle
après la nomination de jean castex était
vendredi à matignon et après avoir passé
le week end avec le chef de l'état pour
élaborer sa nouvelle équipe
il a de nouveau des jeunes est
aujourd'hui avec le chef de l'état à
l'elysée
jean castex qui s'est également rendu
dans l'après midi au sénat à l'assemblée
nationale mais aussi au 16e alors depuis
le début de la journée un pas mal de
de rumeurs en tous cas selon des sources
concordantes des blocages et des
négociations de dernière minute ont
retardé le choix de certains postes clés
notamment le prochain ministre de
l'intérieur qui comme l'a laissé
entendre un jean castex dimanche soir
cela doit changer de titulaires les
rumeurs donnaient jusque là jean michel
blanquer air bien placé pour beauvau
mais un poste aussi convoité par gérald
darmanin tout cela on va le découvrir
bien évidemment dans quelques minutes
on le voit ici sur le perron du palais
de l'élysée alexis colère le secrétaire
général de l'elysée qui devrait dans
quelques minutes
arrivé pour annoncer le nouveau
gouvernement alors on sera attentifs
bien évidemment à la parité 1
on sera également attentif aux alliés du
modem et d'agir que emmanuel macron doit
également contenté l'un de ses
engagements initiaux
c'était au temps de négociation en
dominos qui peuvent tous faire changer
au dernier moment c'est également pour
ça que la journée de la tente a été
longue l'entourage du chef de l'état a
également promis de nouveaux talents on
sera aussi attentif et des personnalités
venues d'horizons différents alors je
vous le disais des rumeurs tout au long
de cette journée parmi les noms cités on
a entendu aujourd'hui celui de roselyne
bachelot ancien ministre sous jacques
chirac et nicolas sarkozy elle est
pressentie pour le ministère de la
culture
alors en attendant l'annnonce de ce
nouveau gouvernement qui est imminente
le gouvernement castex le premier
gouvernement de jean castex
nous allons retrouver jacques myard le
maire les républicains à deux maisons
laffitte il est avec nous pour suivre
cet événement en direct
arte france jacques myard merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur ft france pour
suivre l'annoncé de ce nouveau
gouvernement alors il avait été annoncée
avant lundi matin et puis
eh bien ça a tardé on a patienté tout au
long de la journée qu'est ce que ça
révèle selon vous à l'évidence il doit y
avoir des grains dans les roues bajaj
parce que tout devait être prêt et tout
est débat est il déjà prêt rapidement
depuis dimanche
et rien ne sort donc c'est pire que la
nomination de l'élection du pape
voyez ce que je veux dire donc il semble
qu'il y a à l'évidence des tiraillements
notamment sur le ministre de l'intérieur
notamment sur le ministre de la justice
et ensuite toutes les rumeurs folles qui
circulent montre qu' on essaie d'avoir
je le dirai le maximum de mon unité
alors je ne sais pas si ça va se révéler
exacte
l'entrée de d'une personne que je
connais bien au zune bachelot à la
culture
sur le plan technique elle en connaît un
brin si je peux m'exprimer ainsi
elle était une très une femme
extrêmement cultivé et mais ce qui est
certain c'est que je me demande ce
qu'elle va faire dans cette galère
parce que c'est ça le problème pourquoi
une galère selon vous ce nouveau
gouvernement
il est évident il est évident un que le
premier ministre qui est un haut
fonctionnaire n'a pas je dirais la
surface politique pour mener un
gouvernement
deuxièmement le président la rubrique
est très fragile et il cherchait il ya
c'est toujours en même temps un coup
c'est la souveraineté qui pour dépendre
ensuite il parle de la souveraineté
européenne
il est pour retrouver de la dépendance
nationale mais on sait très bien que il
est idéologiquement ultralibérale donc
je crois que c'est bon aujourd'hui on
assiste à la déconfiture de la macro ni
hivernale il en est conduit est
d'ailleurs visiblement dans les rumeurs
on verra bien ça se révèle aller
chercher à la pêche des gens alex
d'ailleurs de la bac ronnie de cette
espèce de majorité hologramme qui a été
quitte majorité de circonstance qui n'a
pas de cohésion interne
ils tirent à hue et à dia et qui n'a pas
de personnalité pas pouvoir mener une
politique correcte
alors jean 15,6 pour vous jean castex il
a pas ce profil de rassembler un
gouvernement ou avant lui ses parents et
il a des secours que je peux reprendre à
mon compte laïcité souveraineté sociale
oui mais il n'a pas la surface politique
pour s'imposer véritablement parce que
un premier ministre ces noms alors ça
signifie quoi ça si les priorités qu'on
a assisté à une op à de lévis mais sur
matignon
le poste de premier ministre devient
véritablement aujourd'hui une sorte de
direction du personnel loyers se lever
les uns ou un chef de cabinet comme
avait dit en son temps
sarkozy méchamment sur françois fillon
s'est là c'est la conséquence du
quinquennat c'est la conséquence du
quinquennat ou le patron on le sait
c'est l'elysée et on a aujourd'hui un
affaiblissement fort de l'institution du
premier ministre alors le premier
ministre parce que l'article 20 de la
constitution et la a toujours une
capacité à nommer une capacité à
proposer une capacité à mettre en oeuvre
administrativement la politique du
gouvernement s'établit à du président de
la république mais il n'est plus
véritablement comme jadis lorsqu'il y
avait de gaulle dans ce qu'ils avaient
promis 12 lorsqu'il y avait aussi
jacques chirac et giscard d'estaing une
partition des rôles
aujourd'hui on a eu une pulsion total à
sec ce quinquennat qui fait que c'est le
président de la république il n'a plus
de fusible il faut voir où ça nous mène
c'est à dire que tous ceux qui se
rappellent le premier ministre ne pourra
pas dire c'est moi et pas le président
de la république ça ne l'est pas
crédible donc il n'ya plus de fusible
dans les institutions et le président de
la république est obligé de monter au
créneau en faire
danse et risque de se griller est-ce que
selon vous avec ce nouveau gouvernement
il prépare également sa réélection pour
les prochaines présidentielles
c'est ce qu'il souhaite mais c'est en
réalité moi je me demande même s'il va
être capable d'être au deuxième tour
parce que je suis intimement convaincu
que aujourd'hui il est extrêmement pas
utilisé et qu'il n'a plus véritablement
la main sur les événements il subit
surtout qu'il veut remettre sur le tapis
des réformes qui ont été fortement
contestés comme vous le savez la
question des retraites
deuxièmement il prétend qu'il faut
renforcer les pouvoirs intermédiaire
c'est-à-dire les maires des
intercommunalités mais il a repris de la
main toute la fiscalité des communes
avec la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation
donc on est véritablement dans un méli
mélo est dense et plus qu'un en même
temps c'est l'oxymore c'est à dire c'est
la conduite et d'une politique qui n'a
plus sa cohérence interne et je pense
que ça va mal se terminer pour président
de la république
en tout cas il ya un mystère qu'on va
regarder de près notamment c'est le
ministère de l'intérieur on a vu hier
soir jean castex se rendre à la visite
de policiers s'étaient à la courneuve
alors que voilà on va écouter alexis
kohler le secrétaire général de l'elysée
qui s'exprime à l'instar des messieurs
bonsoir
sur proposition du premier ministre le
président de la république a nommé
monsieur jean yves le drian ministre de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères
madame barbara pompili ministre de la
transition écologique
monsieur jean michel blanquer air
ministre de l'éducation nationale de la
jeunesse et des sports monsieur bruno le
maire ministre de l'économie des
finances et de la relance
madame florence parly ministre des
armées
monsieur gérald darmanin ministre de
l'intérieur
madame elisabeth bornes ministre du
travail de l'emploi et de l'insertion
monsieur sébastien lecornu ministre d
outre mer madame jacqueline gourault
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
et des relations avec les collectivités
territoriales
monsieur eric dupond-moretti garde des
sceaux ministre de la justice madame
roselyne bachelot ministre de la culture
monsieur olivier véran ministre des
solidarités et de la santé madame annick
girardin ministre de la mer madame
frédéric vidal ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur de la recherche
et de l'innovation
monsieur julien de normandie ministre de
l'agriculture et de l'alimentation
madame amélie de montchalin ministre de
la transformation et de la fonction
publique
son nommé ministre délégué auprès du
premier ministre monsieur marc fesneau
chargé des relations avec le parlement
et de la participation citoyenne
madame elisabeth moreno chargée de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
de la diversité et de l'égalité des
chances auprès du ministre de l'europe
et des affaires étrangères monsieur
franck riester chargé du commerce
extérieur et de l'attractivité auprès de
la ministre de la transition écologique
madame emmanuelle wargon chargé du
logement
monsieur jean baptiste djebbari chargé
des transports auprès du ministre de
l'économie des finances et de la relance
monsieur olivier du soft chargé des
comptes publics
madame agnès pannier run h est chargé de
l'industrie monsieur alain griset chargé
des petites et moyennes entreprises
auprès du ministre de l'éducation
nationale de la jeunesse et des sports
madame roxana maracineanu chargé des
sports auprès de la ministre des armées
madame geneviève darrieussecq chargée de
la mémoire et des anciens combattants
auprès du ministre de l'intérieur
madame marlène schiappa chargé de la
citoyenneté auprès de la ministre du
travail de l'emploi et de l'insertion
madame brigitte klinkert chargé de
l'insertion auprès de la ministre de la
cohésion des territoires des relations
avec les collectivités territoriales
madame nadia est chargé de la ville
auprès du ministre des solidarités et de
la santé madame brigitte bourguignon
chargé de l'autonomie est nommé
secrétaire d'état auprès du premier
ministre monsieur gabriel attal porte
parole du gouvernement
le président de la république réunira le
conseil des ministres avec l'ensemble
des membres du gouvernement ce mardi 7
juillet à 15 heures je vous remercie
le nouveau gouvernement du premier
ministre jean castex désormais connu il
vient d'être dévoilée par alexis kohler
le secrétaire général de l'elysée alors
on va tout de suite à avoir votre
première réaction jacques maillard maire
les républicains de maisons laffitte des
surprises alors oui alors il n'y a pas
premièrement une très grande stabilité
et en tant qu ancien diplomate je me
félicite que le midi des affaires
étrangères soit remonter immédiatement
derrière le premier ministre parce que
la voix de la france le rang de la
france dans le monde c'est important
mais ensuite bon madame pompili c'est un
retour et c'est une femme extrêmement
engagés en matière d'écologie
à la limite même un peu sectaire il faut
le dire un bon choix après la poussée
des verts justement pendant les
municipales c'était un ministère qui
était très attendu 1 celui de l'écologie
certes mais lorsque vous nommer une
personne
il ya une démarche véritablement assez
ferme et même elle est en faveur de
l'écologie un peu plus nitive donc je ne
suis pas certain parce que le phénomène
écologique est tout à fait ciblés dans
le milieu urbain
donc il ya quand même un problème de ce
côté là ensuite on a effectivement
darmanin qui a réussi à avoir ce qu'il
voulait à savoir le ministère de
l'intérieur et on a deux grandes
surprises une un peu moins parce que son
nom circulait madame bachelot
roselyne bachelot à la culture bon
certes et surtout maître dupond-moretti
à la justice me dupond moretti qui a
dans le collimateur les magistrats du
parquet financier et d'ailleurs donc
j'ai l'impression qu'il va y avoir
quelques explications gravure
donc tout ça me paraît quand même assez
étonnant alors surtout on assiste à une
pléthore de ministres délayer la
coordination de tout ça ne va pas être
simple parce que vous avez des gens
surtout dans le haut de la grand dole
n'est ce pas en tête de gondole vous
avez des gens qui sont quand même
extrêmement qui ont leur caractère dont
les pacéens qui au bas mot je suis
convaincu que de toute façon
notamment monsieur blanc caire monsieur
leproux naulleau mer par lee bon un peu
moins mais et darmanin il pas voilà qui
bat vouloir véritablement marqué ça
c'est que c'est notre compétence ils
vont vouloir marquer leurs compétences
bon donc tout ça à mon sens est un peu
patchwork et on voit bien que il ya eu à
la fois une volonté d'équilibré une
volonté qui ont respecté la parité comme
si c'était vrai tableau de cette machine
à ça me rappelle le plan de table pour
m'appeler au quai d'orsay un homme une
femme puisque à épuisement mais ce qui
est clair
je suis très surpris du fait que
monsieur dupont moretti et de ministre
de la justice et paix loin dans la dans
la nomination et la hiérarchie
gouvernementale comment vous comprenez
ce choix de maître dupond-moretti
justement à la justice alors écoutez ça
ça reste un mystère dupond moretti est
un homme brillant il a une vision de la
justice que je partage c'est à dire que
la justice est une autorité judiciaire
c'est pas un pouvoir et que surtout et
il est en faveur véritablement de la
transparente et aujourd'hui il me semble
que compte tenu des récents propos qu'il
a tenus je ne suis pas certain qu'il n'y
ait pas quelques prises de bec ou du
moins quelques marquage devant du
domaine de chacun donc c'est une affaire
à suivre
parce que je pense que la justice est
une est la pierre angulaire de toute
démocratie mais elle ne doit pas se
mêler de tout je suis intimement
convaincu que la judiciarisation de la
société est une mauvaise chose et que
les juges ne sont pas là pour
véritablement se être mêlé à toutes les
affaires et aujourd'hui pour rien vous
cacher sur les affaires mais plaintes
qui ont été déposées devant le le
conseil de la république la cour de la
république comptait mini ce je suis pas
certain que ça passe à avancer
véritablement les choses
il fallut terminé les commission
denquête et ensuite un passé si
nécessaire s'il ya eu négligence il ya
eu intention de nuire au pénal mais le
mélange des genres aujourd'hui me paraît
pas bon bon voilà donc on va voir
comment ça se goupille c'est une armée
mexicaine à part quelques part quelques
côté titre légal ça droit plus à gauche
comme on vous le voyez au écoutez c'est
assez difficile de ce côté là c'est un
gouvernement qui va être aux ordres du
président de la république et qui étonne
un peu technique vous prenez bachelot
roselyne bachelot est une femme ouverte
est une femme intelligente qui est
capable de compromis mais qui est assez
en matière de culture
elle est capable aussi d'un triplé un
vrai projet j'ai été très étonné
également que monsieur rist rs il est
notamment
alors jean yves le drian et près de 110
de lorient bon visiblement ça n'a pas
très bien réussi à la culture
mais c'est casse-gueule notre culture ne
peux me permettre la culture
donc voilà un on va voir on va voir ce
que ça veut dire
en tout état cause en haut de en dehors
de madame propre il y en au delà décret
de nomination des ministres
il n'y a pas véritablement de grands
changements on retrouve bien sûr
darmanin hop hop on retrouve le corps nu
à l'outre-mer en troublant caire on
retrouve le drian
donc il ya la fois une ou perturber
l'ouverture elle est quand même limité
et ensuite on a une pléthore de
ministres délégués avec les secrétaires
d'état à un point important
bien sûr monsieur castaner et débarquer
ainsi que si big ben est l'ancien pape à
porte parole qui est remplacé par si
j'ai bien compris monsieur attal donc
dans ces conditions c'est pas pour nous
étonner
parce que il y avait mis beaucoup de
même pour se faire virer pour le dire on
a également olivier viron qui restent
ministre des solidarités et de la santé
après la terrible crise vient de
traverser une bonne chose il faut dire
qu'après madame buza il était encore
très difficile de changer de ministre ce
que c'est un ministre qui mérite un peu
de continuité dans l'action
donc on a eu le coup de jarnac et la
trafalgar avec madame busin qui s'est
pris les pieds dans le tapis et qui
s'est comporté de la manière dont on
s'est donc il était nécessaire selon moi
que un ministre compte tenu des
difficultés à appréhender tout ce
système de santé demeure donc de ce côté
là je trouve que cette marque
d'intelligence
merci beaucoup jacques milliard d'avoir
réagi avec nous en direct sur rt france
al'annonce du nouveau gouvernement je
rappelle que vous êtes maire les
républicains de maisons à lafitte et
puis j'ajoute que le premier conseil des
ministres on vient de l'apprendre du
nouveau gouvernement aura lieu le mardi
à 15 heures alors que faut-il retenir de
ces annonces on va tout de suite
retrouvé en direct aux abords de
l'elysée notre reporter katia technique
katia bonjour alors qu'est ce qu'on peut
retenir après ces annonces du secrétaire
général de l'elysée on a les noms des
nouveaux ministres du gouvernement coûté
finalement peu de surprises même si
elles sont de taille
je vais d'abord rappelé les ministres
qui reste en poste inquiets ont été
confirmés dont bruno le maire à bercy
florence parly ministre des armées
monsieur blanc caire à l'éducation
olivier ferrand et la santé jean yves le
drian aux affaires étrangères comme
prévu il y a évidemment un jeu de
chaises musicales entre ministères qu'à
une partie des ministres restent au sein
des ministères même si ils n'ont pas ce
qu'ils avaient précédemment alors donc
de normandie à l'agriculture elisabeth
bornes ministre du travail et de
l'emploi
sébastien lecornu aux outre mer et puis
jacqueline au gourou aux collectivités
voilà pour des ministres des personnes
qui faisait déjà partie du gouvernement
et puis il y à une entrée donc celle de
barbara pompidou transfuge de lv devenu
la république en marche elle elle prend
donc ses nouvelles fonctions est ce que
c'est un choix audacieux en tout cas ce
n'est pas véritablement une surprise
tant son nom circule et déjà alors les
surprises parlons-en
gérald darmanin qui va occuper le poste
de ministre de l'intérieur c'est vrai
que c'est un poste clé un poste qui
était convoité on savait très bien que
christophe castaner était en partance
car il était extrêmement contestée par
les syndicats policiers
or voilà gérard dalmat d'arman as le
choix des manuels maquereau ou du
nouveau premier ministre jean castex
on ne sait pas puisque on avait parlé de
blanc caire à ce poste mais en réalité
c'est désormais à gérald darmanin 2
devait organiser de reprendre les rênes
de ce ministère
maintenant venons en aux surprises
roselyne bachelot à la culture
il est vrai qu'elle avait fait un retour
médiatique assez retentissant
grâce à sa gestion à l'époque elle était
ministre de de la grippe h1n1 elle avait
extrêmement bien réagi en tant que
ministre donc elle a eu un retour de
flamme de l'opinion elle avait été
décriée à l'époque mais elle a fait une
une audition à s'est enflammé il ya
quelques jours donc peut-être est-ce que
celui cela lui a donné des points pour
occuper ce nouveau ministère et puis
évidemment
l'avocat pénaliste dupond-moretti
devient garde des sceaux alors là
réellement je pense que tout le monde
autour de moi mes confrères et bien sont
aussi surpris que moi en effet dû donc
certains avocats extrêmement médiatique
surnommé aquitator un surnom qu'il
n'aime pas mais qui marque son
excellence en tant qu'avocat il
il en est à 140 145 m
acquittement en février 2020 il a eu
pour client patrick balkany abdelkader
meira bernard tapie donc un expert une
nonne hommes de loi extrêmement
compétent qui rejoint les rangs de la
république en marche on note également
la nomination de gabriella talent en
tant que porte parole et donc la
disparition de sib étienne doyon qui
n'est pas dans les listes qui n'apparaît
pas dans les listes et puis marianne
schiappa qui va occuper un poste de
ministre délégué à la citoyenneté au
sein du ministère de l'intérieur voici
pour un certain nombre de noms
sachant qu'il existe un grand nombre de
ministres délégués beaucoup plus
important que celui de l'ancien
gouvernement
merci beaucoup catia pour toutes ces
précisions on vous retrouve bien
évidemment tout au long de cette soirée
katia technique en direct aux abords du
palais de l'élysée alexis poulain
fondateur du monde moderne nous a
rejoint
alexis poulain bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors votre
première réaction à l'annoncé des
nouveaux ministres qui ont été présentés
ce soir et bien 7 déjà remaniement a
minima puisque sont récompensés ce qui
pourtant n'était pas n'avait pas brillé
dans l'exercice comme franck mystère par
exemple et puis on a l'impression de
retour de nicolas sarkozy roselyne
bachelot franck riester justement
darmana beaucoup d'eau le maire
incroyable de voir tous ces sarkozy tous
ump un milieu gauche à nat
ça penche à droite pour vous totalement
à droite et surtout ça penche totalement
vers la récompense du carré de fidèles
dupont moretti à la justice ça c'est
assez surprenant et limite scandaleux de
nommer un avocat qui portait plainte
contre le parquet national financier il
ya de cela moins d'une semaine qui
travaillent dans le cadre d'affaires eu
extrêmement sensibles politiques
le voilà maintenant aux commandes du
ministère de la justice qu'est ce qu'il
y a derrière la tête d'emmanuel macron
on a eu comme ça le juge moreau par
exemple au brésil qui a été nommé par
ball sonar au juge moreau qui a fait en
sorte que lula ne puisse pas se
présenter à la présidence c'est ce qu'on
appelle le lot faire est-ce que c'est à
craindre en france de voir
l'instrumentalisation encore plus du
ministère de la justice que sous nicole
belloubet voilà le des phares dont on en
parlera après mais voilà les premières
impressions c'est vrai que cette
nomination d'eric dupond-moretti
c'est elle qui surprend tout le monde ce
soir comment vous la comprenez au fond
ce choix du président de la république
et du premier ministre vous comprenez
comment ai je le comprends comme comme
un choix extrêmement politique
extrêmement dangereux aussi je
mentionnais ball sonar ou et le juge
moreau qui avait fait cette opération
pour empêcher
lula l'ancien président brésilien de se
présenter à la présidentielle donc il ya
mentaliser tout l'appareil judiciaire
pour empêcher ça comment cet avocat très
en vue qui gère des dossiers extrêmement
sensible va-t-il pouvoir gérer ce
ministère sans s'immiscer sans aller
chercher par curiosité des dossiers qui
l'intéressent lui directement
il ya là quelque chose d extrêmement
inquiétant de voir la façon dont les
choses sont faites sachant que c'est un
ministère qui manque de moyens alors
peut-être que dans la tête de jean
castex et des modèles macron avoir
monsieur moretti c'est pour parler aux
avocats par les hauts magistrats puisque
la justice se porte très mal en ce
moment en france c'est à dire que
quelqu'un du sérail va peut-être pouvoir
arranger les choses
j'y vois moi plutôt le verre à moitié
plein le risque en fait de manipulations
de du ministère dans un cadre de l'ô
faire ou ou là le mélange des genres est
totale et ça c'est extrêmement
inquiétant alors autres ministères qui
était attendu regarder de près c'est
celui de l'intérieur avec gérald
darmanin le disait mais aussi avec
marlène schiappa ministre de la
citoyenneté me semble-t-il qui
travaillera donc aux côtés de gérald
darmanin ce choix il va plaire aux
forces de police selon vous ça reste à
voir
vous savez gérald darmanin il a été élu
maire de tourcoing
c'est dommage pour les gens qui habitent
tourcoing le voit la ministre il a dit
qu'il garderait les deux mandats donc
déjà là on a un petit souci parce qu'il
va falloir qu'il se concentre à 100% sur
le ministère de l'intérieur
donc je ne vois pas pourquoi ils
garderaient la mairie de tourcoing quant
à marlène schiappa je ne sais pas quelle
image et là auprès de la police
elle a fait le travail qu'elle a fait
dans le cadre de ses fonctions
précédentes n'a pas fait grand chose à
part beaucoup de déclarations
malheureusement là il va falloir
reconstruire une police républicaine
sont ils les mieux placés pour le faire
ça reste à voir rappelons-nous la
première visite du nouveau premier
ministre jean castex était dans un
commissariat la courneuve pour bien sûr
dire là la priorité qu'était la police
pour ce nouveau gouvernement
donc m gérald darmanin qui a une affaire
d'ailleurs judiciaire pour pour un cas
de violence sexuelle
voilà qui dit beaucoup
dupond moretti aussi dans l' affaire
outreau enfin ce il y a là une négation
de la parole des victimes et mâcon
voulais faire plus pour les femmes
voilà qu'ils nomment alors présomption
d'innocence bien sûr mais tout de même
quelqu'un qui n'a pas un casier de tout
à fait net compte tenu des affaires en
cours à l'intérieur
là aussi ça pose question et ça en dit
long sur le peu de le peut de fait que
font ces gens là de gens qui sont
victimes
alors le ministère de l'écologie
également un scruté de près avec une
femme barbara pompili ce choix quel
regard vous portez dessus oui alors
c'est ça fait partie de ces de s'élever
ambitieux qui sont prêts à aller à
gauche à droite du moment qu'ils sont au
pouvoir
barbara pompili c'est l'assurance d'un
green washing tranquille un green
washing c'est à dire cette campagne de
promotion de l'écologie qui ne sert à
rien ou fait semblant en fait d'aider
les grandes entreprises de quelque 40 à
faire croire qu'elles sont écolos dans
leur pratique de la pollution je pense
que barbara populiste sera parfaite à ce
poste comme elle est un peu de rugby
féminin donc elle ne fera pas de vagues
contrairement à nicolas hulot qui était
parti lui de manière fracassante
elle s'apprête à faire une écologie de
façade qui va tout à fait avec la
politique et la volonté de non écologie
des modèles ma console dans la
communication donc elle elle sera très
bonne communicante et pas forcément une
très bonne ministre de la transition que
c'est le bon gouvernement selon vous
pour emmanuel macron dans la perspective
de la prochaine présidentielle
c'est un gouvernement qui ne fera pas de
vagues je pense puisqu'il l'a récompensé
ceux qui étaient là dès le début c'est
un gouvernement aussi de la continuité
je crois que c'est important de noter
bruno le maire qui ne bouge pas parce
que l'économie va être un des gros
dossiers de la suite des opérations
qu'est ce qu'il reste du gouvernement
environ 1 tenant en pratique de gestion
des affaires courantes puisque après on
va très vite rentré dans la campagne
pour 2022
donc pour une ré mac compte c'est
l'assurance d'avoir des gens qui connaît
déjà qu'ils vont être rapides dans la
mise en place des différents dossiers
qui connaissent déjà des dossiers est ce
que c'est le bon gouvernement
l'avenir le dira on verra comment ça va
se passer je crois que ça rassure
beaucoup à l'intérieur de voir
christophe castaner exfiltrer ses
rassure beaucoup de français de voir
nicole belloubet mais s'inquiète de voir
dupond-moretti arriver et puis je pense
que certains sont soulagés de voir le
porte parole à revenir à gabriella
talent et de ne plus voir si bête
ndiaye qui sait et bien compromis dans
des mensonges sans fin lors de la crise
sanitaire du coronavirus crise sanitaire
du coronavirus qui sera toujours géré
par olivier ferrand qui reste à son
poste de ministre des solidarités et de
la santé là encore comment vous
comprenez ce jeu ce choix mais elle a
aussi un dossier extrêmement brûlant
puisque cette crise sanitaire n'est pas
fini loin de là qu'il y a eu et bien
beaucoup de revirements de communication
beaucoup de nouvelles stratégies
les français n'ont pas très bien compris
donc s'il devait y avoir à nouveau une
poussée de ce virus dans les mois qui
viennent au différend semble mieux placé
pour continuer de gérer cette crise il
pourra même demandé conseil à roselyne
bachelot même si la culture elle pourra
lui raconter ce qu'elle faisait elle
quand elle était assez de place là mais
néanmoins le message est clair il a géré
cette crise à peu près correctement aux
yeux de l'exécutif donc il va pouvoir
continuer c'était important qu'il reste
parce qu'on en avait déjà changé en
pleine crise avec agnès buzyn qui était
parti pour les municipales donc changer
à nouveau de ministre alors que la crise
n'est pas finie aurait été un très
mauvais signal pour les partenaires de
santé en plein milieu du ségur de la
santé donc c'est le choix de la
continuité on ne peut que le saluer en
tous les cas à quoi allez vous être
attentifs dans les prochains jours dans
les prochains mois on sait qu'il ya des
dossiers brûlants qui attendent le
gouvernement dossiers économiques
sociaux la santé vous le disiez le c ur
de la santé à quoi est-ce que vous allez
être attentif ya la réforme des
retraites aussi
qui va être traité par le premier
ministre oui alors à voir comment cette
réforme des retraites va être traitée de
l'avis de tout le monde les syndicats
patronaux comme les autres syndicats ce
n'est pas le moment de revenir sur cette
réforme
on a d'autres choses à faire pour
relancer l'économie et éviter les
faillites et éviter qu'il y ait trop de
nouveaux chômeurs qui arrivent sur le
marché du chômage pas le marché de
l'emploi
donc il attentif bien sûr à la politique
économique qui va être conduite le
niveau d'endettement mais aussi quels
sont les signes pour aider les
entreprises et pour éviter que de
nouveaux français entrent dans la
précarité
avec cette crise économique majeure qui
est devant nous ensuite bien sûr la
suite de gestion du camp en un virus ce
qui va être la stratégie de rentrée dans
les écoles par exemple puisqu'on sait
que les écoles sont maintenant
clairement identifiées comme étant des
lions de propagation du virus de nouveau
cluster sont apparus dès qu'on a voulu
réouvrir les écoles donc est ce que le
nouveau ministre de l'éducation va non
le ministre de l'éducation a un plan
pour la rentrée jusqu'à présent il n'en
avait pas peut-être qu'il va devoir
travailler cet été
et puis et puis bien sûr tout ce qui va
être de l'ordre de la réponse à bien aux
revendications sociales
que ce soit dans la police darmanin qui
a fort à faire avec les syndicats de
police les soignants bien entendu mais
aussi tous les autres qui attendent de
voir quelle va être la politique du
gouvernement à partir de partir de
maintenant
merci beaucoup alexis poulain d'avoir
réagi à chaud en direct sur rt france
après l'annnonce du nouveau gouvernement
alexis boulin je rappelle que vous êtes
fondateur du monde moderne et l'analyse
le décryptage et bien continue dans un
peu plus à 20h heure de paris ce sera
l'info avec stéphanie de murs eux qui
reviendra bien évidemment a largement
sur l' annonce de ce nouveau
gouvernement c'est la fin de cette
édition
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi à
excellente soirée sur rt france
[Musique]
where france pour renault comme ce sont
des entreprises qui sont en jeu d'hier
est en fête permanente
on va pas obliger les autres plusieurs
pros texte actuel à garder leurs
salariés ça n'a pas de sens ça fait
longtemps que je soutiens l'idée d'
emploi garanti
c'est à dire on propose un emploi toutes
ces personnes ont maintenant qu'elle
retrouve un autre job non on n'a aucune
vision aucune
et ça c'est malheureusement dans tous
les domaines au lieu de dépenser des
milliards comme ça pour rien il faudrait
mieux les dépensés pour former les gens
et les replacer ailleurs
[Musique]
la stratégie politique depuis pas mal
d'années